foreign
Humphrey and I'm with the Rio read Jex
Brian how you doing great how are you
doing John I'm doing great I'm I'm
really excited to talk to you forgive me
for how I'm about to phrase this but I I
dug the [ __ ] out of this this was like a
dream I love a good left turn and I'm
also a huge horror fan so this was like
the perfect conversion to kick things
off I'm curious you know without giving
anything away there are certain moments
in werewolf by night that certainly go
surprisingly hard in terms of the horror
elements some of the gore gags and uh
you know watching MCU joint that's both
fun but also kind of surprising I know
you get leeway with black and white but
words is there any ever any resistance
or any sort of fear that you would sort
of get too close to the line in terms of
that kind of stuff you know it's all for
us it's all about story right and and
one of the components of that is you're
going in Jack is going in with a group
of Monster Hunters the best in the world
they're probably not going to sit around
and chat they're probably going to pick
up their weapons and go after each other
we wanted you to feel that so when you
go into that that garden and you're
getting chase you know you should be
scared you should be worried who's going
to Survive who's not going to survive
what's going to happen what are the
consequences and so we from the story
perspective always wanted to lean into
that and to sort of show that on screen
otherwise you know you don't want any of
those characters to feel toothless you
want them to feel big and scary and
formidable and then as you mentioned the
black and white we love those horror
movies from the 30s and 40s and so when
we said we'll do it we're like we'll go
all the way right make it black and
white put a little film Grain on there
there's some real changes you know the
cigarette Burns in the corners uh things
like that that you'll notice you know
Upon A re-watch probably that felt like
make it feel like this is a horror movie
that someone found in a canister you
know in I don't know the UCLA film
archive or something like that like
bring this out let's see what it is
that's so cool see yeah I think you guys
really nailed that aesthetic and you
managed to do so in a way that feels
very much like a love letter to those uh
you know classic horror movies but
that's also like surprisingly in
endearing and I guess my my next
question would be you know you obviously
have a lot of experience with Marvel in
the MCU but you know this is a step in
you know a step up order or at least a
step two a new role in being executive
producer what was it about this
particular project you know is it to do
with the genre or was it more just this
was the right time you know it's a
little bit of everything I will say that
I do I really like the mummy from 1932
like I like a lot of those watch The
Wolf Man Of course for this but you know
Creature from the Black Lagoon which was
a little later but like you know there's
something about the real people in
Supernatural or mystical situations
that's very interesting to me because
it's grounded but they're dealing with
something that they're completely
outside their comfort zone and for this
one it just felt like oh we can we can
depart we're making the first special
presentation it can be shorter it can
just be this like sort of appetizer of
what's to come with with monsters in the
MCU and it feels like just it was it was
an exciting project to jump into of
course I guess finally then can we can
we maybe expect to see more werewolf by
night in the future there's there's I
would love it I will say that I can't
reveal anything but when you get to the
end of the special wonderful thing is I
don't know that Jack knows what he's
gonna do next like sure any of these
characters are just thankful they made
it through that night and uh you know
without spoiling it's like anyone that
made it I don't know where they're going
I don't know what's happening next
that's a good I I like that that sense
of mystery and possibility and yeah just
to meet Jack and also Ted like like man
the thing at werewolf by and I both
together like such a joy and and I can't
wait for people to see this special so
thank you for taking the time out to
talk with me like I said like I really
love this so I'm so glad to hear it so
uh yeah I really appreciate your time
thank you for awesome thank you thank
you
thank you
[Music]